hey everyone it's Mike Wallace and
welcome to the orthos market analysis
for Friday September 22nd 2017 and it's
Friday finally you know these these
weeks really seem to drag on for some
reason but you know the email easily
closed right up near its high for the
day and you know at the other day we
recovered to close down slightly but
considering that we hit the weekly low
in this session down at 92 I believe it
was and rallied late to close the week
for us a marginal gain I think you know
bodes well going into the weekend and
obviously we'll see if anything negative
happens over the weekend and if nothing
negative happens and you start seeing
some signs of buying perhaps we get a
rally into Monday but we'll see you know
time will tell it's it's only Friday
evening right now now the other thing
you know it seems that the data coming
out for example the PMI is that came out
today it's only showing limited
hurricane impact on both manufacturing
and service sectors again which is good
so what I'll talk about today is I will
follow up on what I discussed yesterday
about huge volume and there were some
great examples today in the order flow
and again it's only information you're
going to get by looking at order flow if
you look at a normal bar chart you're
not gonna see it and if you're a student
off to look for it then you could have
taken some nice trades and they all
gather there's some great great great
signals in the Delta scalper so you know
that's that's sort of jump into it this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation of
buyer seller futures contract or make
any other type of investment decision
futures train contain substantial risk
and it's not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that can be lost it's
not jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for trading in only those
with sufficient risk capital should
consider trading past performance it's
not necessarily indicative of future
results now as usual the same tools I
use of this presentation is just to you
know prove that I don't just jump around
from the latest indicator or ladies
indicators the owner phone's volume
footprint order flows trader which is
the volume footprint chart to Delta
scalper and the price rejector you know
these are the bottom two Delta scalper
and price rejector are tools that read
the order flow for you so it helps make
your trading up
easier so first I'll talk about the ym
the mini doubt today there was there was
a great sign in the market today so
let's take a look
okay so mini Dow this is this morning
here this is 847 you know 830 is the
cash open you can see we moved from o2
up to around the 18 level sort of going
sideways here you got a delta scalpers
sell signal and we came down into this
area in this bar look at this negative
Delta minus 500 but you know bars green
it's an up bar and you know take it a
step further look at the actual volume
that's going through in there you see
very strong volumes you see 355 982 65
550 so you got you know close to 2,000
contracts going through here on the bid
side the market creeps up a little bit
comes back up into this area where you
got this the Delta scalper had given you
the sell you come back down here another
big chunk of volume going through 929
even here at 370 226 you've got pointing
controls lining up here so I know that
there's buying in here I know there's
people bidding the market when I say
buying in this case something about
bidding not buying the offer they're
mostly preoccupied with bidding this
market so you got two thousand here
another you know 1500 1600 around here
as well 2000 between o 4 and O 3 and so
I know that there's support in this
market so you know what do you expect
the market to do do you expect the
market to sell off with respect to
market to rally now I know people might
say well you look at this bar you know
the market sold down yeah okay you know
support resistance is a level it's not
one price right so don't get fixated on
one price again where do we sell off to
we sold off down to this area where you
have the support down here the 550 you
know yet 550 265 980 so you get down to
98 a realistic place to be buying this
is around o 2 O 2 O 3 o 4 and what
happens is you start going sideways some
more some more but again you see is
still seeing buying coming in you know
now it's it's actually happening at
slightly higher levels here o is
happening around the double O level here
it's happening around the oh three level
four level here it's coming in or around
the o six level
so you know you've got buyers coming in
you know you're putting through some
strong volume coming through here
now you finally pop up you pop up a look
you know the next bar here get all it
2:17 here you get up into the 20s now
you're still seeing some volume go
through there then you get this bar here
you got single print you got some signs
of price rejection you've got aggressive
selling coming in you don't necessarily
see the support of buying anymore so
this is a sign that you know it can be
changing on you as far as let's say
changing but rather this this pop up
here is potentially weakening then
obviously next bar down you're not
seeing the support of buying coming in
anymore here you had some decent volume
here you don't see that at all
and you've got negative Delta negative
Delta which is you know obviously not
some good signs and here you come back
down so you know realistically what can
you gotten out of this movement I think
if you got Authentics
you know that's great but you know 20
ticks is you're not gonna get to be
honest now people say wow that's such a
small move well yeah but these are what
do you call slam dunk trades these are
the type of trades that it's so obvious
yeah you would like to market to rally a
hundred points but you know what the
markets got its own thing that's gonna
do you know the aggressive buying you
know we'll see what happens when you
come back down and come back down
where's the aggressive vine it's not
there anymore so that's another sign to
you so you had the strong buying here
strong supportive buying now you're
coming back in here you don't see the
aggressive the supportive buying anymore
by supportive mind I mean what's being
traded on the bid it's not there and the
market starts falling down now you're
starting to see a little bit coming in
here but that's it then the market falls
off so you know if you get on the other
side of the support of mine what do you
expect the market to do do you expect
the market to rally or respect the
market sell-off if the support of buying
that's there earlier is no longer there
what's gonna happen nothing it's not
there's no more support in the market
and you can see the market trades all
the way down into the you know almost
down to 80 here but again you know it's
not about getting a hundred points on
every trade it's about finding things
that you know what I call low risk
trades I mean you know what are you
risking on this trade you know if you're
buying it in here at you know around
this area where the support of buying is
that
Oh 203 what's your risk on the trade
your risk is you know just a few ticks
it's not like you're risking 10 ticks on
this trade no if it starts going against
you here you know you're getting out you
know if your kids pass this the low of
this bar where you have the support of
buying
chances are there's no more support of
mine and that's where you should be
getting out so it's not like you you're
getting in at 2,300 you guys stop at 22
to 90 no your stop is really tight it's
just it's around ninety seven ninety six
if that even is probably more
realistically around 97 98 all right
really quick this is the soybeans lately
haven't get a lot of interest in the
soybeans though people have been asking
about soybeans guys talking about
soybeans I think it's a great contractor
trade and it doesn't get a lot of the
same respect as as things like the
financial contracts but nevertheless
let's let's take a look here so this
morning you know eight 30s they reopen
833 you get to Delta scalp or you know
usually with beans I'd like to give it a
you know from the time it reopens at
8:30 I like to give it about five
minutes so I'm not really looking to
take signals in here yeah you do have
the Delta scalper giving you this buy
but side I don't know I mean it does
rally up eventually there's a much
better sell signal up here now you heat
up you get up here to this high and what
do you got you got a divergence here no
ratio you come right back up with a
bullish bar but again no bullish ratio
here and finally you get them the single
print the bearish ratio but you know you
got the Delta scope or you're on your
high and what do you got you got your
strongest Delta positive or negative and
then in this case it's negative which is
a bearish sign and then you know you
come back here small Delta seven okay
you know maybe you're a little bit
confused what do you do and then boom
this bar here comes in strong negative
Delta six six eight so you know a couple
this one this bar here with this bar
he what you're getting you're getting
very negative readings here you know
even this bar here - 700 so you're
you've got you know three out of four
bars up here on this high our extremely
strong negative Delta's so I said you
got the Delta scalper giving you the
signal here now you've got again you
know something confirming it here you
got the ratio here you've got again
strong negative Delta strong negative
Delta and then the market proceeds to
sell off you know from the eighty three
and a half area all the way down into
you know what is that eighty one then
you know eventually we do poke down
below eighty we get down to seventy nine
and a half before we work our way back
up but you know this was this was a this
was again to me this was a easy trade to
take just by watching what's happening
here in the deltas you get up here you
got the Delta scalper gave a sell you
know okay this one didn't work out but
again you know this one this cell is a
bit different than the cell that you had
earlier up here way over weighted in
Delta negative Delta's I mean it's a
thousand six hundred seven hundred and
even you know like just before you got
some small Delta's 78 177 okay but here
you got the negative Delta 339 okay it's
negative it's not the strongest negative
but then you got strong positive right
afterwards again positive Delta positive
Delta it's just sort of hanging around
here this is your sign over these next
one to three bars if you're short this
that hey you know what this trades not
going to work out let me look at this
words your follow-through selling
where's your negative Delta's in the
bars they're not there instead you're
seeing positive Delta's and then you get
the big pop up here then this Delta 1200
as you come into the high just this
volume just gets scooped up you know 904
trade some very strong volumes up in
here 16 hundred a thousand seven fifty
three hook up to a new high then you
start coming off going into the close
for the day but you know you know can
you take this one of course you can but
you you know this one didn't work out
you could have you know you got out at
small Aussie there's no way you would
have made any money on this trade but
this one was a lot easier and and
clearer to see then and this one this
one you know this is not a good one I
mean it's still a trade but you know you
should be recognizing that it's not
working out in here obviously you would
you'd have your stop just being behind
this level like eighty four and a
quarter eighty four and a half you know
so you know if you don't get stopped out
here say you got a stop a little bit
wider you could be reading what's
happening in here and maybe get out in a
smaller loss but you know realistically
you would have been stopped out on that
trade now this one again you know you
it's never won against you never even
came back up towards there he got within
a tick of the high but again is this one
is a lot easier to be taking because you
got all this negative Delta here are you
getting short you want negative Delta if
you're not getting short and all you've
seen is positive Delta that's not a good
sign
okay now this is crude oil market was
kind of quiet most of the morning
honestly and this is the eight range
chart and we've been in a sort of this
range between you know thirty and sixty
more or less a lot of the most of the
morning and you know just looking for
any sort of signs in the markets and
there really wasn't you know many really
great trades here you had one but again
the market just went sideways I thought
this was you know potentially decent one
you got the fine and balance up on the
top then you come in here with
aggressive selling but then the market
you know next bar sold off a little bit
but just mostly one sideways before
rallying back up and you got up here at
you know ten seventeen you got up
towards the high here you got all the
way up to seventy six then you got the
Delta scalper coming in you got the
Delta surge following it actually yeah
so you got your swing high right after
high of the day negative Delta Delta is
getting stronger minus six minus 48
minus six hundred minus eleven hundred
so you know I know that sellers are
coming in so I thought this was
interesting you know as you got up near
the high of the day what was happening
where buyers coming in where were
sellers coming in in this case sellers
were coming in and they're coming in
strong
you know 1/4 - 48 so earlier you know
you had been rallying up here with some
nice positive deltas 400 500 then it
gets up here on the turn it's - 48 - 600
- 1100 at this point what do you think
this mark is gonna do you think some
markets gonna rally it's gonna sell off
the answer is easy it should be selling
off and what happens boom next bar big
down bar pretty quick actually so you
know it starts moving from you know the
58 area down into the 46 is gets all the
way down in here to you know the low 40s
where you got some sign of some price
support in here then it just sort of go
sideways on you but again you know this
is what I talk about with with order
flow you know someone asked me today you
know where should they start with with
order flow well Delta I think is you
know Delta appointed control and
imbalances are the three building blocks
but I think the easiest way to jump into
order flow is by adding Delta to your
analysis and you can see it here in you
know I said it's this market is just
coming up we're coming up here near the
high how do I know it's the highest
because is this the Green Line is a high
today at 78 and what do you see right
you're coming up with some strong buying
well you get within you know three ticks
of that high why aren't we going to hit
that high instead the selling comes in
you got the aggressive selling year
aggressive selling here with the
imbalances point to control up near the
top so I know that there's some
resistance up here because you got to
have your volume up there and you got a
a weak Delta okay it's 48 you know if
you're gonna be taking out too high
you're gonna need some my incoming and
you're gonna need positive Delta strong
positive Delta not negative Delta and
then in the next bar you got stronger
negative Delta's - 628 okay so you don't
have the buying anymore said you gotten
strong net aggressive selling than even
an X bar even stronger net aggressive
selling - a thousand one hundred
thousand one hundred and thirty what
happens is this market sells off you
know when you're looking at bar
structures like this taking into account
that you just had a rally what do you
expect this market to do like when
you're like I just showed you when
you're staring at it like this
what do you expect this market to do
rally no there's absolutely no reason in
the world
I couldn't go up and what happens is it
sells off I mean that's what the market
does when you're staring at this sort of
structure this price structure say I
don't say this price structure but this
Delta structure you know that that's
again I hate to use the term slam dunks
I'm not that much of a basketball fan
anymore ever since Michael Jordan
retired but again that's that's it's
clear as clear as mud I say Claire's my
clear as day right there for you all
right so this is the bonds you know this
market was give a terrific trading
opportunity so this morning at four
important control at the bottom of the
bar you got your strong vol 5 5 - 4 5 -
you got a bullish ratio Delta scalper
market rallied but more importantly
later just for 8 o'clock you got
something very similar it's the same
price actually o 6 you've got the
bullish ratio you port of control at the
bottom of the bar end up with small
Delta here at this point my concern with
the Delta even the next part you got the
Delta scalper kicking in I mean you got
a nice little rally you know from the 10
area all the way up to you know is that
19 but this bar here you know this is
this is a very potent bar so that look
at this volume here 1772 what happens is
this market goes offered here so it's
six you know a trade six seven a lot
then it actually goes six offers five
bit at six 1400 on the offer traded at
at six nothing traded at oh five and
that to me that's important okay you
know it means that it was offered there
no interest absolutely no interest or
anybody even trade in one lot there and
then the market came back up started
rallying so you got very heavy volume
supporting this market right here and
it's actually the same level as before
now
now again you know I know unfinished
business people say well look for the
market to come back okay
well you know the way people are you
supposed to trade unfinished business is
you look for the pullback here and then
the market to shoot up again not hit it
and come off now but in the meantime get
to that in a second then you hit your
high up here what do you got you got a
ratio and divergence so you got your
signal here to be buying and then you
got your signal up here to get short and
you know this
short hear you're talking you know
you're getting short in this bar at you
know 14 trades all the way down 204 and
then you start seeing some you know port
of controls towards the bottom but you
know this is interesting because you
know earlier here at oh six right is
where you had you know that heavy volume
okay and this is something we used to do
in the bank is you know we'd have these
levels you know where I know there was
support earlier and if you break through
it watch it watch out if it becomes I
hate and not your new resistance that's
because I'm not gonna look at this
resistance but you know it's one of
those things okay we used to sit around
the office and you know people would be
working bids and offers and sometimes
you forget about it right so if here
sitting out a bit here at O six okay
because you know you got a lot to buy
you're buying it okay okay the market
starts rallying you better make sure you
cancel your bid because you know if the
market starts coming back down chances
are if it starts coming back down you
don't want to be only in it anymore
instead you want to be you know the
markets gonna blow right through that
level and sell off you know it's it's
just one of those things you know it's
like it was a great buy here but if it
rallies all the way up here and starts
coming off don't look for it to be a
great buy again you got to be out of
that position and going in the opposite
direction that's why you see a lot of
aggressive selling in here not
aggressive buying and I said the market
sold off a little bit and you know we
just sort of meandered the rest of the
day here but really this was a great
trade here great opportunity this high
was a great opportunity when you came
down here don't be looking to buy it
again you should be looking to be
getting out of it or getting short if
you did could have got a few ticks but
again that's that's something not
everyone would be looking to do but I
definitely would not want to be a buyer
there again alright so this is the euro
currency 5 minute chart I am you know I
just wanted to show you this because
again it sort of came up in a
conversation I had with somebody it's
you know hey can I use a 5-minute chart
well
you can you can use pretty much whatever
chart you want but you know it's it's
one of those things you know you're
using a five-minute chart you're gonna
get less signals so you can see here
right this is the main u.s. session you
got one signal here and one o'clock and
it didn't work but you know then you got
one here earlier this one didn't work
either some people say oh yeah I got two
trades this morning and it didn't work
well okay let's walk it back here did
you take this trade at 9:15 9:20 you
know what you get it moved from one
twenty ten all the way up to you know up
to this area up here to up to 40 you
know even if you held it up to here or
you know at one twenty thirty I'm hit
did sell off back down to twenty even
got down to fifteen but you know this
was a nice trade here I mean to say that
oh you know it had two traits and had
the losers well you just happen to pick
the time of the day with the the two
losing trades
here's a yen this is a five-minute chart
you know there's a nice trade here a
nice trade here a nice you know a small
one here not much here a nice little
trade here again I wouldn't be taking
stuff around 3:00 in the afternoon on
Friday you know even on 15-minute
charges the e-mini 15-minute chart and
we got that you caught the late rally in
the day which was nice this one and
that's not much of a move I don't know
if there was anything yesterday Oh
yesterday you know you caught this you
know the move from three three and a
half you know it looks like a big move
it's only you know I ain't talking about
four or five points here then this one
didn't materialize into anything so I
mean it really depends on the type of
chart I mean just you know again I get
people 233 tick chart in the crude
personally I think that's too fast of a
chart but you know if you're using it
yeah you can get some nice quick hits
hit and run type trading you know Ewing
you know short at 64 covering it down
here at 53 you know a little move here
nothing out of this one yes hopefully
something here but again it really
depends on the type of trader you are
and don't try to you know force force
the market to you know follow that's
forced the market but I mean don't try
to do something that can't be done in
the sense that you know I use a
30-minute chart and I want to trade
Delta you know at that point you know
Delta is really kind of smoothed out for
the day that you're not gonna get very
good signals on you're gonna get very
few signals never mind you know good
signals I think if you're using a
30-minute chart using order flow it's
kind of pointless order flow is you know
best to use fresh you know as the data
is coming in the longer you go out in
the order flow I think the less
effective it is I mean even on a ten
range chart you know you can see here
alright there's not a lot of action even
though I'd still be looking at the same
things you know on a ten range chart
that I would on you know a one-minute
chart or a four range chart you know
here earlier this is last night that
just around nine o'clock you have a
ratio on divergence what happens nothing
the market comes down makes a new low by
one tick then you got the divergence
again you can see it there you've got
the Delta scalper kicking off you got a
nice buy single print here you've got
the divergence and the ratio Delta
scalper you know that's what you want
right what happens is the market just
goes sideways eventually it does work
out but you know for the most part the
market just went sideways and on you
know like today right what's your range
oh one to ninety to a nine point range
so you know be using a ten range chart
when you know one bar is you know
basically the equivalent of you know two
and a half points then you know if it's
gonna be a tight range it's going to be
a quiet day you're not gonna get many
very effective signals so anyway I'm
sort of starting to ramble on here I may
I sound like a half asleep actually when
I listen to myself so thanks for
watching
to learn more about order flow go to
order phones comm be sure to subscribe
to the YouTube channel and I try to post
videos up fairly regularly and if you're
interested in thoughts this couple go to
Delta scalper comm to learn more about
it so thanks everyone and have a great
day bye bye